Colonel uh as you're sitting there uh
thank you for making time for us this
evening want to get your initial
reactions to this and the way it will
likely be received amongst the military
Community especially those that went to
Afghanistan yeah I I think I mean Prince
Harry enjoyed enormous popularity in the
armed forces both for his his his
determination to serve in Afghanistan on
two occasions and also for the help he
gave to wounded soldiers partly through
Invictus Gaines um unfortunately he's
blown most of that away now um and a
combination of his turning on his own
family the royal family which means such
a lot to the armed forces and his
attempts to exploit his own Service uh
for his own publicity purposes and we we
only need to think back about what he
said about how he killed so many Taliban
members uh a short while ago in his
Memoir spare uh for me the greatest
problem with that Memoir wasn't
boasting about killing Taliban
terrorists of course that was his job
and and he's quite right to do so but he
did say and I think it was for the
benefit of his woke friends in
California that uh that he was
conditioned by the Army to treat them as
subhuman as less than human beings which
is simply not true but plays well to the
woke agenda so I think those things uh
have have combined have led him to be I
wouldn't say vilified exactly but
certainly treated with much greater
suspicion and much less affection in the
Armed Force than he was before okay so
you really think he's he's gone down a
woke path let's come into the studio for
some Royal analysis Nina is this what
could get Harry back into the good graes
of the British people well I've watched
the first two episodes of the of the
series and it is fantastic it is very
compelling the stories are wonderful
it's beautifully filmed it's very very
emotional it's actually very moving you
actually I find it hard to watch without
crying at some of the stories of these
incredibly Brave um Afflicted soldiers
and and what the games mean to mean to
them but to but to just to pick out
those two little phrases and
and you would imagine that the whole
thing is about Harry whining on it's not
at all that it's the story of the games
it's story of the people and story of
what the games mean to them and those
two comments that you've picked out when
he said he didn't get therapy when he
when he he may have been advised to get
therapy but you you need to have more
than that I think what he was um
pointing out was that there's the great
loneliness when you come back from
active service and all the all the um
the servicemen said that there a
loneliness you're on you're on your own
and and you it's only when you're in a
fetal position lying on the ground
crying that you realize that you do need
something and he went he went for that
and so I don't see the I just don't see
the problem he's he's done a brilliant
job with the Invictus games he continues
to do that and uh and I think this will
go a long way to showing you know it's
very unfair to pick out these tiny
things it's a five-part series and these
are two comments that less than 20
seconds each Lynn bringing you in for
your reaction uh funny enough I do Echo
a lot of what you say um you know
there's so many people that have watched
this and they've been empowered but the
only thing I would agree with with some
of the commentary is that it is being
slightly disingenuous and I think it is
almost offensive to the services because
um armies the Navy they offer counseling
after and it would have been nice for
him to say maybe I didn't take the
support maybe I didn't reach out but
there was that support available to me
because as we know he did receive
therapy when he was 28 he did receive
therapy after um Diana his mother's
death so it it's a bit frustrating to
hear how he's said it but like you said
I think that we're picking or the
media's picking on these tiny little
things where you know why don't we hear
some of the amazing things where he's
donated masses amounts from even his
libal case he's donated from his Memoir
he's going to donate from this and we
don't seem to ever gravitate towards the
positives that he's doing it's always
these tiny little incidentals that we
hone in on and I think that's just
massively negative do you think you can
understand then why he creates these
Netflix series these six-part series
it's his way of kind of countering that
narrative yeah and I think to be honest
I am one of those who was getting a bit
sick and tired of of Harry uh seeming to
be like a lost puppy behind Megan and
everything was all about you know what
they've gone through which is not always
a negative it that's their truth however
we remember Harry for being this sort of
you know about the invictor games about
his passion for those um service men and
what they went through and I think this
is actually going to win the hearts of
many uh instead of him just him and
Megan talking about much to do about
nothing this has real meaning so I'm
glad that that he's done this let's
bring Colonel Richard Kemp back in then
listening into all of that um very clear
here in the studio people think this is
probably a good move in terms of
rehabilitating his image and especially
with regards to the invictor games which
many consider to be quite a Triumph yeah
I'm I'm personally I have to say I'm not
interested in rehabilitating His Image I
I really don't care what his image is I
think the important thing is the wounded
soldiers who take part in the evictor
games that is the only thing that's of
any significance and I you know I would
really question what what stress he was
under during his tenure of service in
Afghanistan yes he he insisted on going
against opposition to fight and to put
himself in danger but what was he doing
he was he was fighting at very very
remote distance
not the kind of thing in my view that
would result in in serious stress and
PTSD compared to many of the other
soldiers who lost limbs had their lives
shattered and in some cases tragically
were killed I think you know I I don't
think we should be looking at his image
as being something of huge importance to
this except in as much as he can bring
publicity and and bring public attention
to these extremely brave soldiers who
gave so much and I think that this
documentary has that benefit and his
name being on it is extremely important
of course because it brings publicity to
their cause but only if it results in I
would say financial and medical
assistance to them not for any other
reason I don't I don't personally buy
all the the need to rehabilitate His
Image Etc I think you know I think I
think the key issue is how much he can
bring to the cause of wounded soldiers
who still suffer so much today and still
don't in many many cases receive the
support they need can I just say
excellent point Colonel yes please I say
I think that's terribly unfair of of
Richard to say that that he couldn't see
what what could possibly stress Prince
Harry out it's not for one human being
to say to another what can stress them
out anything can stress them out and I
think he he he proved that he was Brave
and he proved in in all sorts of areas
that he that he was willing to and and
and in if you read spare and if you
watch this series you'll see that he
um he empathizes so much with his his um
his comrades he admires them he respects
them and the fact that he started up in
Victor's games to to help them and a
huge positive the interesting thing is
the interesting thing is well when I I
don't know more about the Invictus games
than anybody else does and I just think
well it's it's people who are afflicted
physically but in fact the second part
of the series shows so much of of their
mental and emotional
do you not think it's about it's become
like the the Harry Fest I the hug
disappointing thing for me is this is
about six individuals who obviously had
uh struggles a hard time possibly lost
limbs we should be focusing on them we
shouldn't be looking at Harry yes he's
going to bring in publicity but we're
all here talking about Harry when the
conversation should not even be about
Harry because because the media picks on
Harry if you just watched the series he
knows that and he should have taken
himself away should have those indivual
hardly in it he he present he he's he he
presents it and he he pops up
occasionally just reinforcing or you see
him in a part of a meeting but it is the
story of these Heroes it's the story of
these individuals and that's what makes
it so compelling and so moving and the
fact of the matter is he has facilitated
this he has made this happen without him
this would not have happened without him
there wouldn't be the games without him
there wouldn't be um this series which I
hope people will watch because it is is
fantastically inspirational it really is
well let's put that to Richard then
could it be possible that we'd have uh
all the publicity around the Invictus
games and everything that he's done uh
with that cause without having Harry
feature is it necessary to have him
there to get people interested in
it I don't think it's necessary but I
think it is it's pretty important you
know you need in in in in today's world
you do need a kind of celebrity
figurehead and Harry in many anyways is
the ideal one um and so I think his role
is important in it but but I think as
one of you sorry I can't remember the
names but as one of your guests rightly
pointed out he should not be in in my
opinion he should not be talking about
his own hardship because his own
hardship is almost irrelevant compared
to the the real sacrifices made by many
of the soldiers who are taking part in
the game he should be hosting and and
presenting them and their hardships and
well you know we we I I have to say I
disagree with with one of your gu there
it was it was Nina that put to you that
um he shouldn't be you know the idea
that what triggers people Harry said
that the death of his mother that
triggered him when he was in Afghanistan
of it all came back to him we can't say
what upsets people and what doesn't
shouldn't just be a lot of soldiers a
lot of soldiers have lost their mother
or their father Etc it's not it's not I
mean okay it's a big issue for the
individual but but I don't think that
kind of feeds into the the the the The
Narrative of PTSD which he's claiming to
have I think you know I think it's it's
I I know that an one individual can't
read another individual's mind but I I
think his his priority should be very
much on the on the real sacrifices the
tangible sacrifices made by the other
soldiers concerned now with respect
that's exactly what he's doing that's
exact what doing making this documentary
that's exactly what he's doing he's
focusing on the stories of these people
we wouldn't have known these stories if
the documentary series hadn't been made
we we wouldn't know it he could have
been involved without making it about
him though and that's not about him if
you watch the series it is not about him
it's only because the media are picking
on it it and he has perfectly entitled
to describe his own feelings as a means
of being how showing empathy to the
people who have suffered in other ways
you know if he can talk he can talk
about his mental his mental problems and
and his and and and and all the stress
and Trauma that he has perfectly rightly
you know documented then means that
people who are struggling can feel I'm
not alone and people watching it will
feel I'm not alone if even he feels that
or even you know if if this is how he's
overcome it then I can overcome it too I
think that's fantastically inspirational
well you may well be right there I I
wouldn't totally disagree with that but
but when when we look at the mo one of
the most privileged people on the Earth
bringing his own story into it when he
in my opinion and okay you know it's
only one of many opinions he should be
focusing not on his his travails and
hardships which are nothing really
compared to what many of the other
people have experience he should be
focusing on highlighting what they've
done now great if this if this
documentary does actually achieve that
objective and and if it brings in money
and other forms of support to these
individuals then it's it's worthwhile
whatever we think of all I just want to
bring in Lynn as well because give her a
comment because when I'm listening to
this Lynn what I hear is potentially the
difference between civilian and Military
you're thinking about this very much
from an act of service uh Rich this is
what I'm reading I might may not be
reading it right and N you're thinking
it very much of the sort of normal human
angle and people getting upset by
various things you're saying stiff Upp a
lip I mean Lynn is that what you're
hearing no my my main takeaway from this
is yes I do agree that the media is
picking on Harry and we have a
responsibility to sometimes not hone in
on these incidentals as I prely said but
at the same time Harry is well aware
what the media is going to do and it's
not as if we haven't heard his
experiences before I'm not going to
demean them he has every right to
express them but it would have been nice
if he veered away from talking about
himself and speaking about those who
have really gone through hardship while
being in service as uh the gentleman
said lost limbs and really suffered
during their time so that's the only
frustration for me it seems like you
know once again we're all concentrating
on Harry but I think yes it's a
two-pronged approach where the media are
to blame but Harry is well aware of what
the media is going to pick up but what
he's actually said in the first two
episodes that I've watched wouldn't add
up to 10 minutes you know
so sorry leadership leadership is not
about telling other people how tough it
is for you it's not that that's not what
leadership is about leadership is about
understanding other people's hardships
and helping it's exactly what he's doing
not sure I'm not sure that it does that
by explaining how tough it is for you I
mean you know I've LED soldiers in
battle not for one moment would I
consider uh talking about the
difficulties I have and the problems I
have with them I think it's highlighting
their problems highlighting the help
that they need is the really important
part of this and and therefore I don't
really think what he's okay it may only
be for a short part of it but I don't
think it should be any part of it that
he he kind of tries to evoke his own
sympathy I think there is while it while
I hope this documentary does uh create
Sympathy for the and and support not
just sympathy but support for the
soldiers concerned I I don't think his
you know we we we we don't really need
his own promotion his own image in this
and and I've also you know I don't know
how true this is or not but I understand
that Megan Merkel is going to give a
talk to the to these soldiers about
overcoming hardship and courage Etc now
again I'm not I I don't know what she's
going to say I don't know why she's
saying it but I don't I don't really
think that's appropriate it comes back
down again to the to their overwhelming
need I think to to
rehabilitate themselves having can I
just has
he can I just ask you Richard have you
actually watched the documentary I've
seen part of it I haven't seen the whole
thing now and I also just want to put
the correction obviously Megan marle ly
I could see your face there um H we do
have to wrap this up shortly Lynn do you
have any final comments based on what
Richard was just saying no I'll just say
you know there's there's good and bad to
take from this um I'm happy that he's
done this I'm happy that it's mainly him
and not Megan there I know she makes an
appearance but I don't see the need for
her to do that um but yeah I do think
that we have a responsibility to not
pick on these small things when it's a
massively inspirational documentary but
at the same time just a little bit Fed
Up of Harry going on about his own
experience constantly all three of you
thank you very much for an in-depth
conversation there about this new
documentary